bringing the news that just broke hear
about the the Trump transition teams
saying that their intention here is to
totally do away with the dodd-frank act
there is a huge element of uncertainty
here capital you on uncertainty and when
you're doing this kind of analysis how
big is that variable just wondering
what's going to happen here in the
administration but that's a beautiful
thing about technicals is we really take
away all the noise and you look at the
price action and you know even if you go
before the election what was working it
was it was financial as it was
industrial as it was materials so then
the unknown was who was going to win but
all you can do is go by what is right
now what is when there are gaps you know
I mean like we saw gaps in the Treasury
market we may again if there's any kind
of catalyst for it we make we may cease
in turmoil in emerging markets and if we
I mean does that upset your you're
charting well gaps are short-term in
nature so oftentimes they do get filled
so that's why we didn't mention the
financials gapped up again today that
might have to get back and filled but
gaps usually don't change the primary
trend so again it's not anything that's
been working may have gapped up and that
may mean to be filled but the primary
trend is what we try to focus on and
that tells us for risk assets it's still
the upset before